[Applause]
Shawn Mendes is opening up about his
time with Haley Baldwin the
twenty-year-old musician attended this
year's Met Gala with a 22 year old model
and rumors swirled that the pair were
dating month later she was engaged to
Justin Bieber at the time Mendes told ET
that they were just friends
no we're not dating but it was it was so
fun dude it was it was honestly just
such an honor to be there and Haley is
one of the coolest and most special
people I've ever met and to be able to
walk with her because she's such a vet
she's done it for four years made the
pressure feels so much less on me and I
just really enjoy myself but in a new
interview with Rolling Stone he admits
that they were a bit more than that
quote I don't even want to put a title
on it I think it was more of a zone of
limbo she later unfollowed the stiches
singer on Instagram and is now married
to Bieber Mendez told the mag quote I
texted Haley congratulations and I
really am happy for them she's still one
of the coolest people ever she's not
just a beautiful person visually but
she's one of the most beautiful hearts
I've ever met the heartthrobs love life
has been an ongoing topic in the press
especially from those fans who like to
speculate about his sexuality something
that Mendez says has given him lots of
anxiety quote in the back of my heart I
feel like I need to go be seen with
someone like a girl in public to prove
to people that I'm not gay even though
in my heart I know that it's not a bad
thing there's still a piece of me that
thinks that and I hate that side of me
he also recalls this video that his
friend Taylor Swift posted of him
wearing sparkly eyeshadow
saying he woke up in a panic after
giving her permission to share it quote
I felt sick I was like why did I let her
post that I just fed the fire that I'm
terrified of anxiety is is not a myth
and everybody has their own version of
it and their own reasons for having it
he continued explaining why he's annoyed
by the constant questioning I thought
you guys are so lucky I'm not actually
gay and terrified of coming out that's
something that kills people
that's how sensitive it is do you like
the songs do you like me who cares if
I'm gay and while the pop star got
candid in the Rolling Stone article he
tweeted that he wasn't exactly pleased
with it writing of course I have my
insecurities and struggles but that's
just one part of me sometimes the
positive side of a story doesn't always
get fully told and I wish it had here
Mendez opened up to ET in May about his
battle with anxiety which inspired his
hit single in my blood the song is about
overcoming the feeling it's about
experiencing the feeling and how the
world crashes down around you but over
how you can always overcome that how is
the Shawn Mendes today that we see now
different from the guy that we first met
I'm not as worried about what people
think as much and that shows a lot in
the music
[Music]